maybe you can uh speak to the CF scale
for people who don't know so one one of
the uh sort of mem like principles and
goals of uh the eak movement is to
ascend The Carter shf scale what is the
Carter Chef scale and when do we want to
ascend it the Carter scale is a measure
of our energy production and
consumption um and really it's a lot
logarithmic scale and CF type one is a
milestone where we are producing the
equivalent wattage to all the energy
that is incident on earth from the sun
Carter Chef type 2 would be harnessing
all the energy that is output by the Sun
and I think type three is like the whole
galaxy equ galy I think level yeah yeah
yeah and then some people have some
crazy type four and five but I don't
know if I believe in those but um to me
it seems like from the first principles
of
thermodynamics that again this there's
this concept of
thermodynamic uh driven dissipative
adaptation where you know life evolved
on Earth because we have this sort of
energetic drive from the sun right we
have incident energy and life evolved on
Earth to
capture figure out ways to best capture
that free energy to maintain itself and
and grow and I think that that principle
it's not special to our Earth Sun System
we can extend life well beyond and we
kind of have a responsibility to do so
because that's the process that brought
us here so we don't even know what it
has at store for us in the future it
could be something of beauty we can't
even imagine today
right
that